qu'ils aient été réélu mise en ballotage
ou battu au premier tour
de nombreux maires de france se mobilise
en faveur de leurs administrés face à
cette crise inédite liés au kobus 19è
certains font du porte à porte pour
distribuer masqué gel hydroalcoolique
d'autres ont instauré un couvre-feu plus
de 150 maires ont ainsi interdit tout
déplacement nocturne entre 22h et 5h à
nice christian estrosi est désormais
guéri ducobu 19 a même avancé le
couvre-feu à 20 heures dans certains
quartiers de la ville à partir de 20
heures une fois les commerces et
pharmacie fermée
plus personne n'a de raison de sortir
donc on ne sort plus
sauf les personnels spécifiquement
autorisé par cet arrêté personnel
médical ou social pour ceux qui font des
visites à domicile de personnes fragiles
pour le portage de repas par exemple
j'en ai fait part au préfet et je lui ai
demandé de le renforcer par un arrêté de
la préfecture au sujet du déconfinement
la principale inquiétude porte sur le
retour en classe
programmé à partir du 11 mai qui dit
école dix reprises des transports des
activités périscolaires et des cantines
et noir finie place aujourd'hui au maire
la responsabilité d'organiser ou non les
conditions de ce retour en classe il
faut laisser le maire être en mesure de
dire aux responsables de l'éducation
nationale dans l'école anatole-france ça
va pas être la même chose que dans
l'école jean moulin
parce que les lieux la façon de
s'organiser
le nombre d'élèves inscrits dans l école
rendent plus facile ici que là
l'organisation parfaite de cette affaire
et ça c'est pas moi qui peux le dire
c'est pas le mini de l'éducation
nationale c'est souvent le directeur de
l'école le maire et le représentant
local de l'éducation nationale et j'ai
totalement confiance dans ces trois
acteurs si j'ose dire pour prendre les
bonnes décisions
une reprise scolaire jugée prématurée
par de nombreux édiles qui estime ne pas
être en mesure de garantir la sécurité
sanitaire dans leur ville
l'épidémie ralentit grâce au confinement
et on va mettre dans le même lieu
enfants instituteur personnel communal
sans les avoir testés sans masque et
sans prise de température à l'entrée je
considère cette ouverture des écoles
prématurée la fin d'une épidémie ne se
décrète pas politiquement
ondées confine mais en même temps on met
des freins à chaque mesure annoncée il
ya un mais derrière qui complique
l'organisation pour la rentrée scolaire
par exemple on va se débrouiller seul
toute la responsabilité du retombe
dessus en désaccord avec la politique
gouvernementale le maire d'hautmont est
allé jusqu'à prendre un arrêté pour
fermer ces écoles jusqu'à nouvel ordre
nous n'avons pas de possibilité
actuellement de s'accueillir en
respectant ont leur faisons respecter
les chefs barrière s'agissant des
maternelles et primaires s'agissant des
enseignants ceux ci sont en première
ligne
ils sont aussi concernés par cette
politique sanitaire qui les oblige aussi
à pratiquer des gestes barrières dans un
contexte difficile comme je viens de les
lui que les mots clés il ya en plus les
parents et nous savons que pertinemment
que nombre d'entre vous n'avez pas
l'intention de remettre
aux enfants dans les écoles publiques le
11 mai et nous sommes absolument pas
capable de respecter les consignes
d'hygiène sanitaire s'agissant de la
restauration scolaire
même incompréhension cette fois en ce
qui concerne la fermeture des bars et
restaurants le premier ministre le
reconnaît le virus n'est pas présent sur
tout le territoire alors certains
s'interrogent pourquoi fermés partout on
vit une crise inédite
on peut comprendre que ça tâtonne un peu
il faut aller de l'avant en restant
raisonnable et on aurait pu faire plus
de différenciation entre territoires
cent des contrats et des baisses des
dotations et quelques 1500 maires et
conseillers municipaux ont démissionné
lors de la première année du mandat
présidentiel d'emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui ils sont nombreux à déplorer
un manque d'écouté de la part de
l'exécutif notamment pour la gestion du
corona virus